are you aware about the abortion rights
in the United States and what you have
to say about that like women I think
just had their rights taken away for
abortion in certain I don't need the
right to an abortion I'm careful with
who I sleep with and I use protection
yeah but why do I need the right to an
abortion if you're raped that's that's
less than one percent of abortions
so but let's talk about the 99 of
abortions because that's what girls do
when they don't have a good argument
they look for the exception to their
role that's the exception
I know people who have been raped and so
a lot of rapes also go underreported
because it's a very shameful thing to
happen to women and also they don't have
the evidence and so it's even more
shameful to go and accuse someone of a
crime when they don't have evidence what
evidence do you have that it's
underreported
so how do you know how do you know how
do you know that it's under report